i i honestly believe that we all have a
calling and if we actually followed that
calling
there's just such power in numbers to
come together and make a difference and
i believe everybody has the ability to
do it and everybody has the ability to
lead
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
this episode is all about doing good
welcome to 20 minute leaders and meet
shelley hunt the ceo and founder of
successes by design
dane shelly hunt's gift of
transformational impact has taken her
clients beyond motivation to lasting
results through teaching the precise how
to in the design of your success from
the inside out
global entrepreneur business strategist
international motivational speaker drama
expert author of the successes by design
series and tv executive producer
delhi hunt welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you for joining me all the way
from orange county california how are
you
i'm well thank you it's good to be here
i'm really excited for these 20 minutes
because these are the types of episodes
that i leave energized and inspired and
looking to to promote change in my own
community and shell you're you're a huge
humanitarian your dame shelley hunt
you've received
incredible awards and recognitions from
from some of the most important
organizations and people in the world
for the great work that you're that
you're doing you teach
you are an entrepreneur you you found it
and and are leading women of global
change and you know making literally
making the world a better place and
specifically with the focus on on women
and so shelly tell me a little bit about
how you see your own career because
you've done so much you've been involved
in so many things you're still doing so
much
who is shelly hunt in your own
perspective
um shelly hunt is and i joke about it
it's the crazy lady that thinks i can
change the world right and make it a
better place
um
but i am a business strategist by trade
um and a trauma expert by trade
um
but i was traveling
with people um for other companies a lot
of fortune companies and doing work for
them
and i decided i wanted to go out when
they were traveling me around the world
i decided i wanted to go out and see the
world instead of just the airport the
hotel
the conference or whatever the meeting
and then back right and um at one point
i said i want to go out and see the
world like what's really here and i was
in fiji
and it was about 20 years ago when i was
in fiji and i said take me to
where the people are
and they took me to this village
and um i'll never forget it my mom had
my daughter and she was watching my
daughter while i was traveling
and
she said she called me and the minute
that i stepped into this village and my
assistant was in this cab with me and
she wouldn't get out yet
it was squalors and um
uh my mom said how are you i said
horrible and i had tears coming down my
eyes
and i said
i just feel like i can't do enough but
there's something i can do as an
individual
um
and that was the start of women and
global change as i said i have these
great mentors and these great people
around me and how do i activate
others
to make a difference on the face of this
planet and um
you know so
that's really where it started that's
incredible
that can you can you share with me a
little bit more about that exact moment
that aha moment that you had
well you know what's funny
on my desk this is this is that moment
baby carriage and it was two sticks with
a wheel
and um
as you can tell they live in you know
squalors and things like that and um
uh they were growing ground food
for their food communal living
uh and
i fell in love with the people
and i fell in love with
um
i guess i just i realized that
we can make a difference
and you know i went well i'm one person
what can i do
and i went no i i can
engage other people to see the world
and to
see other places and it was funny
because people wanted to learn business
strategy from me
and so i started this women at global
change international summit and i went
okay if you want to learn business
strategy for me because i work for some
of the best in the world then come on
over we're going to go to like jamaica
or we're going to go to
wherever and they were like oh it's this
great you know um
kind of five-star vacation and we're
going to learn business and also and in
the middle of it i would make them serve
in the community and most of them
hadn't been exposed to
what is truly 70 of the world
and when i started looking at the
numbers i was like this is how
a lot of the world lives and 70 of the
world is women and children in poverty
um
yeah and so anyways i i started making
them serve on the ground
why
well what led to the inspiration though
of you understanding that
that your ability to be a catalyst and
to recruit people
as a movement as an organization is
greater than your single ability to be
on the ground and
and simply help yourself what was that
spark
that led to that understanding because
that that's leadership in the end
it is leadership um
and
i think it was um
really the the
vision and the belief
you know when i looked at it i went
who am i
who am i to make a difference who am i
as one person
um
and i went wait a minute
it all started everything started by one
person
by one person and when we stand and what
i realized is when you stand for a cause
greater than yourself
there's an energy and there's a magic to
it
um
and it's almost a renewable energy
source
truly
um
you know and so it was a cause greater
than myself
um that i believe people
related to and realized that they could
start to make a difference too
and then
yeah one small thing
can change so much
so
i think that was part of it
how did the organization grow you know
was it simply organically what was you
know sort of your experience growing
this thing it's still growing
and um
you know uh
it grew organically
um
you know i i was doing these
international summits for probably about
10 years
and somebody came to me in 2016 and said
you know i'd like to do a chapter and
i was like oh well that sounds great you
want to do a service project okay in
your local community
and um
the next thing i knew because i had done
some work in the u.s and some work out
of the u.s every year
and so i probably had two or three
projects a year one international and
several
national
and when somebody approached me and they
said well we want to do a chapter i was
like yeah sounds great then i had no
idea
like
the growth that was about to
explode um and you know one of my
sayings in businesses never ever ever
say no to growth
figure it out right
that has mastered it and figured it out
you know like start looking at systems
and things around you um that that have
engaged and worked
um
and so
i said okay and the next thing i knew we
had two chapters and
um
you know of course i
the hardest part being a visionary and a
humanitarian is you have to go to the
back lines
and figure things out um and systems and
procedures and all this stuff which is
not my favorite place to live okay
i'd rather be on the ground with boots
on the ground helping
um
and i had a great team
i had a great team that stood for causes
bigger than themselves to make the world
a better place
and i don't think i could have done it
matter of fact i it wouldn't have been
the same without them
um
and so i i give them and and all of the
chapter presidents a lot of credit but
you know i i've always felt like it had
a life and a breath of its own
you know and and uh
you know i i respect all religions but i
always say it's kind of you know like
god's work it's sources work
it's
bigger than myself
and i believe when we stand for things
that are bigger than ourselves
and
we get ourselves out of the way
right um how we think it's supposed to
look or how we think it it's you know um
and especially when you're doing new
things because this was new
you know before i was like well i have
control of everything i'm running the
projects i'm doing this i'm doing that
and then i went well how am i doing this
let me teach others how i'm doing this
let me teach them how i'm you know
engaging community and leading community
and i went
this is really what i wanted to do in
the long run which is
have leaders step into
their greatness as far as leading
community
and um
it's interesting because you know
many of them we we collaborate with a
lot and i'm all about collaboration
i believe there's power in numbers
and when i first started women of global
change i was picking up the phone and i
was calling all these women's
organizations at first
and i'm like i want to collaborate and
they were like no
but i want to collaborate no
well
they're playing when you when you play
that way you're playing a smaller game
whether it's in business or
in service you're playing a smaller game
because
then it's
more
we're playing
in lack
like they're gonna take from me instead
of we're gonna expand together
and you know that's an old system
that's been in place and it's all around
the world you know if you look at the
business systems you know i gotta
protect my own
and it's like but how do we grow you
know how do we grow to hundreds of
thousands of people how do we grow to
half a million
and how we do that is power in numbers
and in collaboration and it's got to be
a win-win collaboration
it can't just be you know we've had
people that came in and said i'm just
going to promote my business and i'm
like
okay
but that's not collaborating
collaborate
if we stand for a cause that's greater
than ourselves and i don't care if it's
in press or media like we're
we're
bringing light to the causes that we
want to shine light on okay
um for other people to see
well
then you can mention your own stuff
you know and so um
it's all about collaboration and so i i
think that you know but it's hard it i i
can't say it's easy there are times
where it it's um
challenging
and exciting and
i think the biggest thing was in 2019
we did a yearly conference and we
brought the chapter presidents together
and i said i want you to look at all the
projects they've done
and
we went from
historically like three projects a year
to almost 30 in one year
and um everything from
partnering with the britney spears
foundation for children's cancer center
to
um
honduras
roatan honduras where we helped
those under two years old
no longer we weren't the soul
you know company that did it or
organization that did it but we were
definitely a part where we ended
childhood aids
under two years old and that's really
when i realized the power
was that honduras
um
uh experience because we had gone in and
i had picked honduras to do a project
and i i always kind of like pray and
meditate and go where are we going and i
was like we're going to honduras and
they were like what and i go yeah we're
going why
i feel called there
have you ever been there uh yeah once
but i'm called there
um and i don't know why but we're called
to serve and um
we went in and there was a canadian
nurse and she wanted to start a infant
care unit center for babies that were
dying of aids
and so we went in and we built this
building two different buildings one for
the moms and other kids and one for the
nurse
um and we loaded it with formula for two
years because the aids rate is very high
and because of starvation
they nurse the baby
and so i didn't realize like a mother
and father can have aids and a baby can
be born without aids
and so the minute that the mother puts
the baby to the breast
then the baby gets aids so what you know
what are you gonna do do not feed your
kid have a die of starvation or
you know feed it right and so we went in
and we did a year's worth of formula and
i went back
six years later and
they told me that the age rate of
children under two in rowitano
on honduras sorry was zero
and i was floored
i just cried
and i went
you they've been living like this for
generations
you know and um
this changed in six years
like holy crap and when i went back they
said well now we need a school because
we're not prepared for all these
children to live
so
you know we converted it to a school
and um that's when i really realized
the power
the power that
we have together
in our hands
to truly make a difference on the face
of the planet i i believe that
every person has a purpose
and when people come to me and they go
no and i'm like
you do know
is it children is it animals is it
environment is it what is it
and maybe you just haven't ever voiced
it like if i had a magic wand and you
could
you know
really
like serve a cause
what would it be
you know and i think so many times we
separate this is our business and this
is our cause
and
you know i i honestly believe that we
all have a calling and if we actually
follow that calling
there's just such power in numbers to
come together and make a difference and
i believe everybody has the ability to
do it and everybody has the ability to
lead
um
and you don't have to have it all
figured out i didn't have it all for
heck i still don't have it all figured
out okay
so
you know and people go well i need to
have money to start i have to figure
this out to start i gotta do this i
gotta do that no and you know well i'm
doing a nine to five you can still do a
nine to five in transition into
a business that supports
your calling
so that
shelly this was a inspiring and
wonderful if you were to go back
you know perhaps to that same experience
in fiji
no what what piece of advice would you
give shelley hunt today
knowing what you know exp having
experienced what you've experienced
what is something then this is obviously
i'm asking you as a young entrepreneur
wanting to see what if you have to
distill for this one really deep lesson
you've gotten
what is it
anything is possible
you know um
having the people around you that
support you
and that you can share your
big dream with
that's not going to poo poo on it
and so um
you know it really got to a point where
it's like if i shared
my
my big dream
with someone and they poo-pooed on it
even the people around me if they go oh
like the people that work for me if i go
we're going to do this and they go
we're going to feed 10 000 kids 10 000
meals which i just did this not that
long ago and they went
i was like you're fired
so you know um
it's having i guess if i was gonna say
anything it would be
having
the people around you
that really
support
um
you know where you're heading and where
you're going so that
when
i doubted it
they'd look at you and go it's okay go
for it
it's okay or even if something didn't
work they go it's okay
you know um i really think who we
surround ourselves with i know who we
surround ourselves with is extremely
important
you know and people go well there's so
many people around you you know um
but my inner circle is my inner circle
you know and um
you're better to have a handful of
people
that are truly in your corner
no matter what because you're going to
win you're going to fail you're going to
do all these great things and i don't
like to say fail i guess learn
because i definitely learned along the
way
um
but i think that that's
the first piece of advice because in the
very beginning i hired a lot of my
friends
um
and
i actually ended up having to let
quite a few of them go
and i don't mean as friends i mean as
working with me
right and that was very hard um and they
some of them weren't very happy about it
i'm sure
you know it had to be that this was
what was to grow you got to let go you
can't hold tight
and try to con that's the other thing
you can't control everything
you actually have to like
allow other people to be in their lane
completely
i i guess that's what it would be stay
in my own lane
and and anything is possible and shelly
i really want to thank you for
first for for the amazing work that you
you're doing for the world and for the
lives that you've impacted the lives
that you've saved and
not only saved but but improved
dramatically uh broken circles broken
you know
the different ideas of of what they
maybe thought was possible and and and
just as importantly bringing together a
group of people that are mission driven
and they work together to collaborate i
love the way that you tied the the
understanding of growth
and collaboration is not simply as as a
non-profit idea but it's something that
is
as business strategy and and after all a
non-profit or in any organization it's
it's business driven and business
creates impact and so i think that what
what you were talking about was very
very inspiring for me and will leave me
thinking for quite some time now so i
really want to thank you very very much
still very much impressed with this the
biggest mug that i've ever seen uh which
obviously shines you know the the most
important part of who you are and so
thank you very very much ellie i
appreciate it
thank you and have a beautiful sunday
thank you
you